Alright, now that we have added some gameplay, we have added background objects, adjusted
our visual effects, our lighting, and set up our project to make sure it loads the level
we created. We're now going to take a look at publishing our project for Windows. But
before you do that, there is a few things that we need to do. First off, if you haven't
done so already, you'll need to install Visual Studio Community in order to continue the
publishing process. This is because we need a couple of updated SDKs and .NET updates
in order to get the required files to successfully create a Windows executable. So again, just
look for Visual Studio Community in your favorite web browser and then download it, install
it. Once you've installed it, make sure you restart your computer, then launch your Unreal
Engine project and go up to platforms, Windows and package project. Once you've done that,
it is going to take a little time depending on the size of your project. It could take
a few minutes, it could take a few hours, really depends on how much content is going
to be packaged. But once it is done, you're going to get something like this. You are
going to get a executable, an RKIS is going to be boxhunter.exe and when somebody launches
that they're going to be able to play your game from the beginning, the middle to the
end. So let's go ahead and pop over to the editor and check this out now. So again, to
publish this, we're going to go up to platforms, we're going to go to Windows and package.
I'm going to come up to here, I'm just going to hit delete because I've packaged this before
but I have my desktop and then you'll need to make a new folder and there's our boxhunter.
So we're just going to say select folder and now it's starting to package and if we do
our show log here, we're going to see the log of our package. So we'll be back right
in just a few minutes once this is finished.